[Musique]
la table
c'est à rochefort que nous avons
retrouvé jacques demy et son équipe
après les parapluies de cherbourg mag
bodard productrice jacques demy
réalisateur michel le grand compositeur
se sont retrouvés afin de réaliser la
première comédie musicale française
les demoiselles de rochefort
ces demoiselles se sont françoise
dorléac et catherine donneurs ayant
respectivement comme partenaire jim
kelly et jacques perrin cette
distribution est complétée par danielle
darrieux michel piccoli est george
chakiris que nous avions découvert dans
west side story
là
oui
non
[Musique]
oh
tous
bon
[Musique]
là bas
non
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ban
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
m
pas
l'amendement monde
m
[Musique]
adoré les noms
dans la famille dollars
le
[Musique]
et
petit
il y a
[Musique]
il
chiche il a cette bouderie des hommes
dida
deux salons limité ménard
d'esprit démocratique il du poète ans à
la vie illimitée
je pourrais parler de ces vieux le ses
mains je pourrais tu parler de lui
jusqu'à demain
son nom
c'est ma vie et j'avais une vision de
l'amour ce n'est pas l'amour trouver
est il prêt
et tim
et in motion banques
contrerait car je sais qu'il existe
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la raison d'état
le plus fort à son ordre à saloir
personne ne révise jeunes y résister
pas
je le cherchais partout j'ai fait le
tour du monde
de venise un java de manière encore
deux jeunes victoria devenu saint
jacques on
je ne les ai pas trouvés et je la
cherche encore
je ne connais rien
et pourtant je la vois
j'ai inventé son os j'ai entendu sa voix
j'ai dû signer son corps et j'ai peur
son visage son portrait l'amour ne
feront plus qu'une image
elle a cette beauté des filles
romantiques et d'un botticelli le regard
innocent
sans profil est celui de ces vieilles
midi qui hantent les musées
le son
sa démarche ressemble aux souvenirs
d'enfant qui trotte dans ma tête et dans
cet enlèvement
sur son front sèche
100 $ en bataille que
vent de la mer et le soleil
essama
je pourrais vous parler de ses yeux de
ses mains
je pourrais vous parler d'elle jusqu'à
demain
son amant c'est ma vie mais à quoi bon
réveil gelé cherchait partout je ne les
ai pas trouvés
jacques perrin pourrait peut-être oui je
répète ses qualités il n'y a pas un
titre ce n'est pas une chanson vous
répéter pour les demoiselles de
rochefort
oui le tournage du film votre playback
et bien écoutez ses pairs cette chanson
est la chanson clés du personnage de max
en ce que je fais et c'est une chanson
où ils cherchent ils évoquent la femme
idéale la famille des ligues qu'il a
toujours recherché et auquel pourtant
levé prête déjà des yeux définit d une
bouche très précise enfin déjà il a
complètement dessiné en lui et il
cherche à travers le monde
rencontrer ce visage qui s'est déjà créé
et d'ailleurs et le pid et artiste
peintre et il a peint le visage de cette
fille est cette fille ressemble
étonnamment à une jeune fille à une des
deux soeurs des demoiselles de rochefort
qui est catherine deneuve et beaucoup de
moi je crois parce que quand jacques à
ce que françoise et moi nous allions
perdre le fil il a mis beaucoup de nous
mêmes dans les personnages c'est
important je veux dire sans changer son
histoire je crois que c'est très
important quand on connaît une
comédienne les côtés vont à la personne'
et décide de le remettre des choses de
ta propre personnalité
pour les aider en suisse pour avoir
exposé à neydens dans certaines scènes
avait beaucoup aidé et des choses que je
trouve qu'ils sont un petit peu moi je
crois que c'est pareil françoise de
caunes a beaucoup de complicité comme
dans tout il est des récentes plus
facile de rire avec cette viande prenait
bien
[Musique]
sp pas à ces tulle et soyez chic nous ne
voulons pas vous êtes antipathique ne
nous paraît pas à vous cogner dessus à
bras raccourcis
j'avais du sang jusqu'ici c'était une
petite vieille eau ou blanc cheveux
c'est proprement dit monde je n'aime que
les blondes c'est très gentil pour moi
monsieur
ne vous fâchez pas je n'aime que les
blonds mais ce n'est pas parce que vous
êtes au risque avec un couteau
je vous ferai en morceaux pourquoi
seriez-vous c'est ignoble sadique ma foi
non et vous j'enseigne la musique parce
que ça me plaît moi je fais de la
peinture abstraite mais j'ai une
ambition concrètes
je cherche vainement mon idéal
à
alors je les peins chez moi venez le
voir une fois nous ferons connaissance a
créé maxence le jour vous avez su vous
alliez faire la comédie musicale de
jacques demy que vous alliez être la
partenaire de jean caby à ce moment là
que j'ai eu peur affreusement peur et
puis ensuite je me suis mise à faire
j'ai travaillé dix fois plus une la
première fois que j'ai commencé à
travailler jeune kelly et et que j'ai
commencé à répéter avec lui c'était
abominable que je tremblais j'étais
complètement paniqué il lui a commencé à
s'ouvrir et vous inquiétez pas ça va
être tout évêque très facile
quelqu'en soit dans sept mois philippe
de culte happy days une grande dit
pourquoi vous accorde ce prix là alors
j'étais encore pu paniquer puis s'est
mis à rire et puis tout était très
détendue la première fois que je lis eu
enfin du monde m'a dit tu sais ton
partenaire badiane kelly j'étais
complètement affolée mais attends je
suis très très heureuse d'avoir d'avoir
tourné avec lui très très heureux
bonjour bonjour bonjour jean callet gene
kelly vous cet acteur acteurs
chorégraphe metteur en scène hollywood
vous a consacré aujourd'hui vous n'êtes
rien dit miller dans la comédie musicale
de jacques demy les demoiselles de
rochefort
une comédie musicale réalisée en france
loin des studios de hollywood
ce n'est pas la première fois que vous
tournez en france vous y tenez en france
avant gg tous les deux-trois fois en
france mais c'est la première fois que
j'ai essayé de tourner en fond c'est
beaucoup de différence pour ses
aventures j'aime beaucoup et
certainement l'accent et c'est terrible
mais c'est amusant et la chorégraphie
colère régime je sais très bien fait de
crayon gras cru et c'est no mad men et
des jeunes engrais ya les bonnes idées
les graves ou très moderne très up trio
compromise américain dit comme ça moi
j'aime beaucoup
vous avez travaillé avec nous mêmes et
mènera encore cgg travail seulement avec
michel le corre avant plusieurs fois
mais la première fois avec nos premières
actions très content très content très
conscient qu ici on mange bien et il
s'est souvenu
nous sommes de faire signer des nues
face à l'avenir et les limites face à
tarson red hot tout nous donne
n ayant qu désamarrer tôt il passe la
mire et les meet a tall sall rideau nous
vous sommes toutes de m'élever par maman
qui du temps où ce prix bas travail à
bayamon
elle voulait de nous faire des érudits
et pour cela vendre toute sa vie des
frites
non ça veut tout donner le père inconnu
cela ne se voit pas mais quand nous
sommes venus nous avons tout de l'autre
dire assez fou là un grain de beauté
qu'il avait sur la joue nous sommes deux
soeurs jumelles nées sous le signe est
déchets m'ont mis face à l'avenir et
rémy face à sale raidô et ryû tourner
les calembours et les bons mots mais
face à la ville et rémy pas un seul
salaire et d'eau
[Musique]